sixty-five players people keep joining
66 average rating 1806 time handicap
okay let's just there's about 70 players
I'll get it right it's an average rating
of about eighteen hundred time handicap
30-minute tournament should be a good
one let's go let's roll let's go let's
roll
Oh why play checkers alright
pre move pre move we move oh I'm feeling
it I'm feeling it oh oh come on do it
Castle you know you want a castle darn
it okay why did I do that
oh oh my dropping stuff over here right
here is where you want to be I think
what am i doing just come back here or
no let's do this why that though I don't
know about that move
get out of there Knight you gotta go oh
I'm in trouble
I can't castle even I can't castle they
might fall for it oh I'm in big trouble
I think I'm in big trouble
I'm on the night I'm on the night they
missed it ah things are good things are
good or are they check-check
looking for me I got this square covered
what's my what's this guy doing I have
the Queen maybe over here I want to give
a check sneaky check looking for mate
next uh-oh back rank mates right here
this is mate one two three
resignation back to chairman six how
does somebody up sick
two games in six five four here we go
okay there's no time to breathe here
I might be holding my breath like you
know who like I did in that one
tournament might have to David Blaine my
way to some wins here cuz when it gets
down to the wire I just for whatever the
reason I hold my breath yeah breathe you
just hear like a giant exhale like
actually that's an inhale you know what
I meant though give a check no no no no
d6 I'm dropping a bishop though I know
I'm not I'm getting a bishop back again
the bishop back be scared I'm on the
Queen as well but they take my bishop
and they're on my queen I'm on their
queen let's go here if I took at the
pond there's a check-in my knight is
dead I'm on this square be scared I
really don't want to take that and open
up the file over here I really I still
don't want to take that I'm not gonna
take the knight if it goes there okay
what's the scoop over here
pinpoint now the Knights just gonna
block don't you dare fall for me get
over here
rook get to the C file do something oh
okay that was a bad idea by me I'm
dropping stuff what's the clock count
you got to get out of there Knight I
cannot deal with you I gotta hit the
bishop what's the scoop clock situation
hit a bishop get on e6 scary night oh
this pun is going down quick if I'm not
careful
am i careful okay okay tricks tricks
everywhere check I got the bishop let me
do a check first or something one of
these to give a check first
and then take the bishop with the check
and then pile-up on the night because
he's pinned and pile up on him again cuz
he's still pinned okay they resigned no
they didn't they're down on time twelve
eleven ten and I have a measly six let's
go see five for the win
chop this up get your queen to c7 and
look for stuff on h2 you know you want
to get to eight
- h2 is where it's at that's where the
fun happens that sort of things get fun
oh the anti fishing pole g3 and I have
to do something else okay I need to
defend d6 a little bit okay actually am
i right with this I think it's come here
and then here and then plant my knight
on e5 and say you are okay with having
doubled pawns because you have control
over the D file and maybe get a piece to
the d4 square and that's gonna happen I
think oh I have enough coverage for this
miscalculation resignation both okay
there we go
yes 1412 a bunch of 12s all right what
do we have what do we have when we have
double the points windmill fast player
win Oh our Oh Temple gainers quick quick
resignation kill the Queen
kill the knight fracture the structure
kill the knight Forex and stuff tricky
Forex right here queenside castle with
the check with check that's mate that's
mate that's mate back to tournament that
was a quick win
I needed that one 24:20 that guy isn't
top he has five out of five a lot of
time left
whoa a lot of time what do we have in
here okay chess five five zero seven
zero all right aha what's going on with
that they were sniffing out Queen c7
okay so much for that but I have a
sinner though I could say that I could
push them around maybe push them around
and not push them around anymore just
hang on no I don't want you to expand
with tempo no expansion like that I'm
opposite the Queen that can't be too
comfortable okay now the knight can't go
here actually because well it could no
I'm actually getting material it's
backed up I mean I should plate here
this is their best piece get rid of
their best piece okay now I could do
some checks okay let's go here now for
it's maybe too late and I need to get my
okay
keep this closed over here actually I
want to get to this my knight wants to
do something else eventually and wants
to get to c4 can I make that happen I
should have done with a move a move
sooner well sooner I should have ran
with right here although I'm in checking
distance with the knight a little scary
get out of there clean enough Queen
trades oh I just dropped two rooks I
didn't how they can recapture open this
up no no right here first no I don't
know this first I'm on the clean oh this
is a killer I'm on the roof they
resigned back to turn them in 30 36 30
29 oh man okay keep going keep going
keep going here don't you dare give up
don't hit a speed bump whatever you do
do not have to speed bump okay I almost
hit a speed bump my bishop was ready to
be cooked oh I almost fell for the eyes
I fell for that before is this the same
guy that I played against where I'm okay
maybe not let's see I don't know I just
I almost that that move is just so a
typical I think it might be the same
player pawn push Bishop h6 Knight f4 Oh
Bishop takes h6 uh-oh uh-oh
mate threat main threat pawn push
doesn't save it okay I gotta go here I
guess I got a rook I'm gonna chop that
Knight up pins pins pins pins more pins
oh I'm in check there's no mate is there
Oh more pins everywhere more pins where
the pins where the mains oh its mate
right here Queen takes here that's mate
that's meet that's me yes I'm glad I saw
that went back to Turman 42 I have a
lead 42 36 that guy's right on my heels
though there's a couple of them guppy
guppy double O 9 okay
okay I thought it might seem bishop to
have four again oh we might be having it
come on Knight g4 let me play that
please please please please
Oh mate threatmate threat H - H - I
tried telling your back to turn
5650 that was another quick one Oh
twenty-one minutes left a ton of time so
far there's a lot of games in and Wow
a lot of game I should play to f4 okay I
got a reinforced d4 I'm gonna take like
this actually no not okay I want to get
rid of the LightSquared Bishop my knight
wants to be somewhere else you gonna
sent me I want you to be on 85 can you
believe that believe it it's a good
square if you push I go here and if you
don't push it's uncomfortable pawn push
rook pawns they love attacking Knights
that are in b3 b6 g 3 g6 because they
don't have a good response usually
keyword unusually queenside castle
that's a giant thorn a giant thorn right
here if you Castle there I'm looking for
mate on g7 made on g7 I'm hoping for it
might happen in two moves real soon
bishop here is tempting maybe main -
tricky stuff making one - I was just
talking about that he's a giant thorn
right here this guy aged 6 just resigned
they resigned back to Trent 7250 Oh 20
minutes left a lot of time remaining 20
minutes okay this guy's Stefanovich no
way that this guy would fall for a
fishing pole there's no way right it
doesn't happen at this level right wait
a second though that's a bad move on my
part this is a weird pin I'm gonna deal
with it though it's I have it secured
and the dark squares get rid of the dark
square bishop and then plant a knight on
d4 but let's get castle before you're
killed
Castle before you get killed Knight d4
incoming incoming push your beep on hit
the night push the beep on
temple gainer development all I could
have taken the bish up why did I take
the bishop I got it though mate watch
out for the tricky mate wits check I
want to keep the Queens on the board
actually uh-oh I have the safer King you
should be scared making one threat
running for the hills
get out of there rook oh they should
resign shouldn't they they thought I was
gonna give a check they resigned back to
tournament ninety seventy five fifty
five eighteen minutes left a lot of time
remaining we're not even halfway there
can you believe it believe it I say that
a lot can you believe it believe it okay
now the Knights gonna play here or not
okay f7 I wanted target f7 real quick
cannot come quick enough can it okay
well well well well maybe I should have
masked de a-- upon push coming up oh the
Knights running away he's a wonderful
defender and he's no longer there come
over here Queen back up Bishop chase
that night away Oh Oh be very scared
the knight is leaving h7 serious problem
mmm I don't want to trade incoming
Knight g5 no I don't want to trade watch
out for Bishop here chase that Queen
away okay he's got to go get out of
there clean you're giving me a problem
yes I got a bishop resign okay but
Knight here or something
okay let's trade now no material don't
you dare give me um crazy checks got
this guy I guess the knight is running
out of squares and I can't move why
these are precious seconds Oh what's
happening why did why am I gonna do that
mate
that's soon Oh matin 1/2 no it's not the
[ __ ] a block they didn't block
that's a quick main back to tournament
110 95 still in the Hills no he's helped
115 I'm the one who's chasing now
stefanova again gonna have that same
line again I want a material or yeah I
want some material last time right I
worked myself into a pin we're gonna
have that again ha not this time
nope not this time ok what is the scoop
still maybe something with the dark
squares still something I could take
with check it's an important point okay
now I get d5 in good break I want to
target c2 c2 is gonna be the plan get
rid of the bishop if it tries to go here
to defend I'm gonna take here and then
push here if they don't defend against
that pun okay let's open up this file oh
I should have done that this is gonna be
okay I hope this works out is this
working out not really
oh I mean a flight square here's a
flight square ah oh I got a guard
against this that was the wrong flight
square to go with and that pond is
really really fast I should have went
with the H pond that would have been
better right here I guess defense back
rank mates okay I gotta go here they
don't have a flight square let's open
this up please let this work I'm on that
pond twice does this work back crank
mates back rank mates they don't have a
flight square oh man I fell for a sneaky
move I'm dead out of any time I can't
win this can I can I win this still can
I save a draw Oh sneaky tricks give a
check any move come back here defend
upon defend here defend here
no time oh I'm dead what am i no oh I'm
dead there's a check now now I'll get
out of the checks I'm on the rook
I got a pre move uh I don't have any
time back determine oh that one stuff oh
did that one sting really bad ah I
thought I was being sneaky with the back
rank stuff and I got back ranked they
back ranked me they got the last laugh
ah man can I recover from this let's go
don't you dare give up his ecigs you
could do this smash this open hit the
Queen grab a pawn give a check land a
check over here actually this is a mate
take tonight it's a main - oh that would
have been beautiful
I think Bishop check and then night
there would have been good get out of
here 9 I should have taken the bishop
it's just open lines more lines open up
kill a knight give a check look for me
Oh discovered everywhere where are the
Mane's these Knights need to give me
okay Knight check okay I got a matin -
that was kind of quick back to
tournament 128 don't you dare count me
out 13 minutes left
13 minutes that guy is still 12 out of
12 he's probably ready to win a game oh
okay that was sort of quick I need a
quick resigner maybe to get me back in
the ball game 13 minutes left it feels
like this time it's been going on a lot
longer all right let's go I'm on the
pond what are they gonna do in a push ok
and ok we are in full effect here move
Knight go somewhere he's not going
anywhere
ok just pawn push ok well I'm gonna get
chased away here
let's do this provoke this pond move yes
okay now maybe I don't have to run away
my night anymore and now I get on the
light squares I could take that bish up
maybe I should have done that oh I
shouldn't have done that I'm dead no I'm
not I had that and then I'm gonna take
this cuz around the night they're on f7
at the end of it oh okay I have to deal
with it got to deal with that
rook takes I play here I guess it's a
little scary but um okay I got to defend
like that night here I think is pretty
good done that I need to get a read that
night you need to go right here rook
takes Bishop might be played uh-oh I got
to take the knight if that happens that
would have been bad that would have been
really really bad
I think rook takes Bishop right there I
got a defense stuff over here it's ready
to fall apart
oh right here pawn push I could be doing
that let's get out get out of there rook
and open this up quicker quicker than I
am get out there night and over here I
think is safe pile up
okay I could do this if this opens up I
have enough defense right my queen wants
to do something else
oh there I got the Queen they're out of
time though that's the problem didn't
have any time any move no time back to
tournament 148 I have a lead oh I wasn't
the only one who slipped up you see okay
chin again this is the first time though
okay f4 head of three canceiied castle
Queen e1 Queen h4 d 3 f5 Bishop h6 look
up and over look up not over so quick I
don't want it I don't wanna drop that
guy let's stop b5 although it might be
played still I think it's still good
get out of there Queen you're nothing
but trouble open this up right here my
bishop wants
play okay and I really this is a sad
thing to do right here I don't even know
I did it okay this is good though
what am i doing okay wait a second wait
a second where's I just want to push
here I think yes I think pushing there
is good idea is it no I should have done
that first or not okay now now now now
this is like Fisher Benko that's me
that's me back to tournament 168 1:30
what's happening here
like I have two losses 168 ah is bad ten
minutes and change ah Smith more players
no no no no no give me these dark
squares right here this is where I want
to be look at the dark square weaknesses
when your opponent has a lot of pawns on
one particular color complex it's the
other squares that are weakened I should
have done that okay I'm gonna take it
it's a free pun that's a free night
there's no compensation for this is
there I'm just gonna castle and then oh
I should this is don't hit the whole
family right there Knight see - that was
the whole family now could have went
down in flames
Shaq no take a bishop don't you dare
castle not so fast I should have given a
check maybe Oh matin one - unavoidable
unless a knight place - there we're not
matin - or something
no now it's me okay good back to
tournament 188 130 whoa am i running
away with it now he's probably ready to
win though eight minutes and change
we're gonna see 188 130 130 120 900 70
let's go with the same old Grand Prix er
primo primo sort of night out I've seen
this before
deja vu King side castle are they gonna
counsel King side really I'm still gonna
do this move because I want to get at f7
and I want a week in the d5 square
let's get rid of the night and plant to
plant a piece right here it's got to be
good actually let me grab a pond now
while that bishops obstructing the
Queen's view okay let's come home maybe
here was better let's take this knight
give a check first and then play my
knight here hit the Queen she's running
out of squares I want to play a four and
if before I want to play c3 I'm gonna do
this right now
the Queen's close to dead isn't she
uh-oh she's hit she's hit again take the
pawn I get the beef I'll open up the
beef I'll take this pawn or Bishop okay
man over here take this pawn oh I'm on
the bishop forking again how many Forks
can you miss in a game over here beef
I'll push they're gonna double up don't
you dare stop at night stop them cold
right there open this up right here
Oh Bishop takes Knight okay wait a
second I want to cry I know I still have
this actually it's a little scary but I
have the Queen isn't doing anything
exciting they should still be okay I'm
gonna take the bishop and push the pawn
this is good check this is me check and
then me the queen is dead
order the king is dead I mean 208 177
minutes left
okay these next few games are gonna be
key if I could get two more wins
actually if I could get three more wins
earlier come for my throat what's that
what's that Queen move doing I get a
pond and the bishop pair okay I get that
Bishop okay
oh okay now I was thinking a fork maybe
hang on with these Primos
all right don't know what to expect here
Queen check I could block yep okay
they're gonna grab the pawn Navy
and what else what else what else I just
want to get developed I don't want any
of my time to be ticking away it might
be fishing pool if they Castle oh I got
the rook if I want it I don't know if I
want it yes I do I should have hit the
Queen maybe let's get my night out uh I
can't castle pawn push I play Queen h4 I
should have okay just go here so I could
castle and complete my development take
that beep on already there we go now I
could take here I could play rook here a
lot of stuff again f3 okay I could get
that Bishop in between her and what else
okay my rook is going crazy on the first
rank right here grabbing a lot of stuff
pawn takes just anything actually I
don't want any seconds to come off back
to tournament 228 195 minutes and change
I could be paired up with one of these
top guys here oh the last time I played
this guy he'd beat me I think part of
the reason was um I was fearful of I
wonder if it was in a two-minute game I
was fearful of him actually being a GM I
think this was the guy on ICC with a
similar name who's a beast
okay weaseled my bishop around and hope
for the best
okay now I'm actually not as fearful cuz
I think I have a better position now
okay Knight right here I guess is gonna
be played okay get mine I just I want to
get out of here that's the main idea
there and okay let's come here I'm on
this there's also forks forks forks
let's open this up I think time
situation is good actually yeah I think
that that was a two-minute game oh I had
a fork how many Forks can you miss in a
tournament that's like the seventh fork
right there
geez hit upon
let's take care and then playback it's
gonna be trapped I take the night okay
they get that we just do that I'm not
quite sure why but let's just do it and
I'm not sure why I did that move either
okay let's trade
I just want to trade I have a time edge
I have material edge
let's get that clean out of there
looking for the f7 square they got to
give it up now
Oh check and then mate real soon
check why can't it be easy this is check
and then I could take here as it was a
pre move just hit the Queen Oh looking
for this square right here on d7 let's
take care in between her and then take
the bishop or pin it no matter what I go
here pin work them in a pin keep them in
the pin anything okay they resigned back
to tournament 248 to 4000 three minutes
and change oh it's really tight it's not
a runaway oh I didn't mean to do that
don't you dare baby step it what is my
opponent doing what's going on here
they're giving me the win are they
giving me the win they're giving me the
win yes back to term at 268 haha three
and change oh I have an edge I have a
two-game lead if I get one more I think
it's sealed let's see come on you could
do it you could do it you could do it f7
get this one right here and I think it's
sealed although honestly I thought it
was sealed even earlier I played this
guy earlier too all right I want to get
over here and hit that bishop and then
play e5 chase tonight away there goes my
main ingredient my main man he's dead my
LightSquared bishop I need that guy
around he's nowhere to be found though
uh Knights gonna move okay I want to
keep my knight around I guess the
Queen's could be coming off any second
you know their night and that Bishop I
need to get rid of the bishop there's a
lot of stuff I need Oh
pac-man mode Oh dark square weaknesses
come on pound push actually defends me
but this doesn't Oh Queen check I could
dodge it its mate next eventually just
get out of that and then mate next there
might be one more check that's it
unavoidable g7 resign maybe I could
sneak in one more no I don't want the
Queen I want the king 288 261 minute 45
what's it gonna be
WN okay I have enough time I think to
get this one
I've control over that square and no now
I don't have that what's happening here
they gonna give me a center i got a pond
I'm hit im hit at like a ton of times
okay this is weird but I have to do that
before I could Castle what's that night
doing these are gonna bother me ah
tricky stuff the night is on a different
square it's easy to miss that let's come
back home get that night out of there
you need to go somewhere else and defend
oh I'm dropping that no not then I could
play here oh I have a pin this is resign
time
get out of there night Oh a little bit
scary a little bit scary a little bit
scary give a check okay I could dodge
this though let's get developed get rid
of the tricky night and everything
should be okay that's the plan get rid
of a tricky night and then everything
should be all right and I'm gonna do
this I might be having naughty play here
if the Knights chased away
okay 27 seconds 25 seconds don't tell me
I'm gonna need to win this one and I'm
not gonna be able to win what's what's
the scoop here where's the mate oh they
resigned yes back to tournament I got it
ten seconds nine eight seven six five
four three two one it's complete got the
rook I got the bishop what do we got
what do we got what do we got
they're making me play again still no
yes I'll take it first
plays confetti all right that's where
it's at look at the confetti that's it
everybody wants that it's a look at all
the different colors Oh fun stuff
okay close that good games all ahh
all right 308 I made into threes 282 29
to 20 181 160 etc all right